r.kelly I wasn't taking requests but
that's interesting what can I say about
our Kelly except still listening to it
in my car when nobody's around I'm still
not remix in ignition remix doing I
swear to God let me give you that
everybody be like - probably how we trap
them women I don't even think it's like
chains or anything like that I'm ready
to leave let me give that to my mind
isn't even telling me no right now this
is crazy him Wow okay but they just keep
put on 12-play - and see what happens I
don't know we're here bro or Kelly you
know what's funny is we gave a [ __ ]
about Michael Jackson for 48 hours
that's it that's all we gave you I'm
gonna give a [ __ ] about this for 48
hours and then we're gonna stop talking
about it
and then about a year we're just gonna
slowly sneak it back and do a playlist
or two and then life will go on nobody
still gives like all you guys are I get
the eerie silence cuz you're like what
is this guy talking about
when was the last time you said you were
disgusted by Michael Jackson in any
conversation the day after it aired and
most of us probably didn't even watch it
cuz it's like look I don't I don't want
to know that about Michael Jackson can I
please just keep listening to [ __ ]
Michael Jackson well you guys kind of
ruin every playlist on earth look is
wrong with these people just spoiling
all our fun that's what Twitter is
Twitter is just let me spoil everybody's
good time what do you love oh let me
[ __ ] it up for you
you guys love laughing let me tell you
why this joke is offensive you guys to
let you go oh you love our Kelly wait
till you hear this
shut up shut the [ __ ] up and hear those
girls screaming in the dungeon if you
shut the [ __ ] up
[Applause]
we'll give a [ __ ] man you already took
the Cosby Show now I gotta lose [ __ ]
Michael to does the eighties mean
nothing to you people want to know you
don't gonna [ __ ] about the whole
greatness of the decade [ __ ] man